is she just being Miley or is Hannah
Montana coming back on Thursday Miley
Cyrus debuted her new do on instagrams
first by sharing this moment of her mid
dye job file and all then brace yourself
she shared this and oh my god the
internet is losing it because she looks
just like her former on-screen alter-ego
[Music]
before you go raining on my parade
saying that it's just a wig
Miley made sure to clarify that those
long blonde locks and shaggy bangs are
all her frankly guys I'm shook I feel
like it's 2006 and I'm locked into the
Disney Channel with a peanut butter and
jelly and a chocolate milk with a funny
straw anyway
Miley shared the info behind her new old
look on Instagram you know buddies it
was so hard going back and forth that I
decided I'll just be Hannah forever she
was getting a lot of press this week
thanks to me and Miley Hannah whoever
wasn't kidding the internet was abuzz
talking about the show's recent 13 year
anniversary Hannah Montana aired from
2006 to 2011
have you had enough nostalgia because
Miley wasn't even close to finish living
her best Hannah life she shared tons of
videos of herself rocking out to some
classic Hannah Montana tunes but guys
this one is my personal fave Miley
looking like Hannah
singing MIGO says 2013 song Hannah
Montana I can't
[Music]
Miley jumped on board the 10 year
challenge posting this side-by-side and
declaring herself the winner of the
hashtag 10 year challenge listen in my
humble opinion she just won the freaking
Internet and while Miley brought Hannah
back into our lives and I feel like all
is right in the world again she also
gave the look a fresh updated Punk vibe
and here's Hannah in a chic as hell YSL
ensemble ET was with Miley on the set of
Hannah Montana where she opened up about
saying goodbye to the show and all the
things she learned while filming when
you start out at 11 on a show you have
no idea who you are you don't know about
hair makeup wardrobe and what you want
to do and what your future is and as you
grow up on a show you start to learn
more and more and more that about that
and when I look back I'm like I look so
different and I don't have the
confidence that I have now now I know
exactly like what I want to do when I
love film and I've learned so much and
this show has definitely given me that I
think it's definitely got me prepared
for what the rest of my life is gonna be
I cannot even believe that it's been 13
years since Hannah Montana premiered
that makes me feel kind of old I'm not
gonna lie to you but my week month and
year was just made by this throwback so
Thank You Miley of course we'll keep you
up-to-date with all things Cyrus so be
sure to subscribe to all things et in
the meantime I'm Hallie Stephens bye for
now
you get the bed
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]